a great player like Tom Brady you know
obviously leaving that's a big deal it's
headlines you know for us every single
game game in the NFL is a tough one and
I think any player can attest to that so
we're not gonna take any one more
lightly just because you know even
though you know one of the greatest
players it's not the greatest player of
all time left the organization we're not
gonna take him anymore lightly Sam darn
on the video conference earlier this
week he's in California during the
pandemic Adam GaSe the Jets coach said
last week on the pft p.m. podcast they
delay their virtual meetings until 11
a.m. Eastern to give darn 'old time to
sleep which is something I've thought of
Chris when you've got guys all over the
country you have to factor in the
reality the some of these guys are in a
different time zone all together but
eventually they'll be in the Eastern
time zone in the AFC East and as of
right now there's a lot of symmetry in
the caesars odds to win the AFC East
this year the Patriots in the bills or
Co favorites at plus 120 and the
Dolphins in the Jets Arco long shots at
plus 800 again that number means plus
120 you bet 100 to win 120 or you bet a
hundred to win 800 if you take the long
shots have the bills really close the
gap on the Patriots to the point where
they are Co favorites or have the bills
possibly surpass the Patriots in your
mind I mean I think that's really the
question I mean that they closed the gap
last year you know III think that's what
we got a like revisit I don't think
there was much of a difference between
the Patriots and Buffalo Bills last year
other than you know an experienced
quarterback a battle-tested football
team and head coach that you know have
been there and done that I think that
was about the only difference I see
between New England and Buffalo now the
big question is yeah did they pass them
up and I think they did pass them up I
do would the offseason the Bills have I
mean the Bills killed the offseason once
again and you know I'm a I'm a huge fan
of what they do up there but I think
when you take into account you know the
losses that the Patriots had other than
Tom Brady I mean you know Danny Sheldon
Jamie Collins
I'll been doing there's a number of guys
there that they're gonna miss that we're
important to their football team and
then you look at the players the bills
added through the draft Stepan digs in
the trade and some other guys of free
agency
I think the bills in my opinion are the
leaders in the clubhouse as of right now
in a FCS
there's still a mystique there that
needs to be overcome and so many of my
watching the last dance on ESPN that
that time that you need to bust through
the ceiling against a given opponent
like the Bulls against the Pistons like
the Pistons against the Lakers I mean
there was that time in basketball where
until the Bulls took everything over you
would have that transition where the top
dog eventually gets toppled and it feels
like now is the time for the bills or
someone else in that division to top of
the Patriots but you know Chris just
like last year when we were getting
ready for the playoff game between the
Titans and the Patriots and I said I'm
not gonna bet against the Terminator
until the Terminator is fully and
completely liquefied and ultimately the
Terminator was liquefied on that
Saturday night the Terminator still runs
the AFC East and I'm not ready to rule
out the Terminator until I see it from
one of these other three teams yeah well
I hear you I'm certainly not trying to
disrespect the New England Patriots
right now I'm not counting them down and
you're right there is something of that
mystique and there is something to just
in general how that organizations run
and how they do things on a daily weekly
basis that always sets themselves up in
the best position to win games on a
Sunday during the fall so they're still
the Masters at that and yes I know Tom
Brady's not there but you know New
England they got an eye for quarterbacks
and I for people who they know want to
lead their football team and I think
they see something in Jared Sid and
they're gonna find the right formula I
truly do believe that and I think the
big thing too is you know again I think
what a lot of us me included sometimes I
forget here is the Patriots defense yes
they lost a few players but it's still
special it was the number one defense in
football last year they tried to improve
that defense through the draft this
offseason you know just here recently to
where you know I still think whether
Jared stood
hits the ground running or hey it takes
a little bit for him to get a speed
underneath them and get a feel for the
NFL I think the Patriots will still be
highly competitive if that's the case
because of that defense and their
ability to stop people from scoring and
putting up big yards and Chris a point
that Peter King and I were discussing
yesterday in pft ot about the schedule
for this year about the uncertainty that
will linger over the NFL all season long
about the importance of being flexible
and adaptable to any and all changes
that may come there's no organization
like the Patriots that can adjust and
adapt on the fly you start moving the
cheese around on the Patriots they're
gonna go get it other teams are gonna be
like what the hell's going on this isn't
fair
oh this is wrong oh we don't like this
we don't like that the Patriots are
gonna keep their heads down they're
gonna keep going and the more you change
the more determined they're going to be
to stay right on pace with where
everything is yeah they don't make any
excuses bill doesn't let that creep into
his mind that type of stuff it's kind of
just like all these are the rules that
the NFL set this is what we have to do
and this is what we're gonna do I mean
that's what they're not gonna think
anything more than that I mean that
that's that's really their special one
of their special abilities is to stay
focused that way and not worry about
things that they can't control let alone
they are the masters of the sports
universe in detail efficiency and always
trying to improve those things in a
yearly basis to make their practices or
preparations that much better to where
they can squeeze more in into a short
period of time because we're detailed
and we tinkered with the schedule for
the last thirty years to make it so
efficient that we can fit every little
thing into the day and leave and feel
like okay we've got it all accomplished
so yeah from that standpoint right I
mean you're right Mike I think the whole
AFC East closed the gap a little bit but
I'm certainly like I think the Patriots
are a playoff caliber football team
still I'm not coming off that ledge and
I do think that this uncertainty really
does benefit the Patriots and I
guarantee you that Bill Belichick
have a plan for every eventualities
the season could be shortened or this
could happen or though fans here how do
we handle a game where we have no fans
one week fans next he'll have everything
buttoned up who have everything ready to
go and if you give him a short a period
of time to turn something around he's
gonna turn it around with whatever time
you give me he's gonna have his team
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports